recording in progress
okay so uh good morning everyone uh here
from ottawa it's an interesting time in
the capital uh it's a dylan robertson
with the winnipeg free press i'll be
your moderator today uh they'll see the
neutrogen
techniques
this is a technical briefing on covet
vaccines
uh there are no reporters in the room so
we'll be taking the questions off of
zoom
we'll be joined today by dr sapria
sharma the chief medical advisor to the
deputy minister at health canada dr mark
belcion the director at the bureau of
medical sciences
dr theresa tan the chief public health
officer dr howard new the deputy chief
public health officer and we'll also be
joined by dr matthew tunis the executive
director for the nazi secretariat who
will be responding to questions but not
giving an opening remark
so with that being said uh we'll take
questions on the call here uh you have
one question one follow up in questions
and uh we'll start with uh jacques
gerald from the toronto star
hi can you hear me
uh hello yes
okay terrific oh i'm sorry um the
speakers need to speak first that's my
mistake i really apologize we'll go to
dr sharma first sorry about that
thanks dylan
no problem uh busy times um so bonjour
good morning afternoon uh to everyone
thank you for joining us today we're
here to talk to you about health
canada's authorization of novovax's new
vaccivid covid19 vaccine for adults 18
years of age and older this is the first
protein subunit vaccine authorized in
canada to prevent covid19 and is another
tool in canada's toolkit against this
virus after an in-depth review of the
evidence we have determined that this
vaccine meets the department's stringent
safety efficacy and quality requirements
and detailed information on health
canada's review is available on the
kovid 19 vaccines and treatment portal
at covid-vaccine.canada.ca
while the clobin-19 vaccines
predominantly in use in canada are
mrna-based the novavax vaccine is a
protein subunit vaccine
and the protein sub-vaccines contain
small pieces of viral proteins that have
been specifically selected for their
ability to trigger immunity they can
also be stored at refrigerated
temperatures from 2 degrees celsius to 8
degrees celsius which will facilitate
distribution across the country
this vaccine has the same objective as
the other covet 19 vaccines which is to
expose a person's immune system to the
sars cov2
spike protein and activate the immune
system to make antibodies to neutralize
it the next time the person's is exposed
to the virus however the approach is
different
mrna vaccines contain molecular
manufacturing instructions for our cells
to make the spike protein with a protein
subunit vaccine a modified version of
the spray protein itself is delivered
these vaccines cannot cause covid19
because they only contain small purified
pieces of proteins and not the virus
itself
the protein subunit vaccines are already
used for other diseases such as
hepatitis b pertussis and influenza
like for all vaccines uh people who are
vaccinated gain protection against cobit
19 without ever having to risk the
serious consequences of getting sick
from the virus
in clinical trials of about 45 000
people the overall efficacy of the
novovax vaccine against symptomatic
copin 19 was approximately 90 percent in
individuals over 18 years of age
it was 100 effective at preventing
severe disease when giving a court given
according to the authorized dosing
regimen that is two doses 21 days apart
this efficacy data is based on studies
conducted during earlier waves the
pandemic preliminary data available at
this time suggests that the vaccine also
produces neutralizing antibodies against
the omicron variant but more data is
still needed
as a term and condition associated with
the authorization novovax is required to
provide health canada with data on
protection against current and emergency
variants of concern as it becomes
available
i know there are likely some questions
regarding the effectiveness of this
vaccine compared to the mrna vaccines
however comparing vaccines is
challenging as the clinical trials were
not designed to test the vaccines
against each other
that said all authorized vaccines have
been shown to be very effective at
preventing what matters most and that's
serious illness with copin 19.
the authorization of additional vaccine
can only help and provides an additional
option to fight this pandemic
so today health canada has published a
number of documents on the covet 19
vaccines and treatment portal related to
the approval
including a high-level summary of the
evidence we reviewed the canadian
product monograph regulatory decision
summary and the terms and conditions
associated with the authorization
with respect to safety common side
effects with this vaccine include pain
and tenderness at the injection site
headache muscle pain fever and chills
the majority of adverse reactions and
clinical trials were mild to moderate
severity and resolved within a few days
although also these side effects are
typical with most vaccines
across all clinical trials of the
vaccine two cases of myocarditis appear
to be associated with the vaccine
both occurred in young men after their
second doses and resolved completely
two other cases were possibly associated
with the vaccine however these
participants were also dealing with
severe acute infections that were more
likely to be the cause
three cases were clearly unrelated to
the vaccine
any potential risk of myocarditis with
the novavax vaccine will be closely
monitored once it's in use however the
initial data suggests that this
potential risk would be very very rare
and the benefits of the vaccine continue
to outweigh its risks in all of age
groups
with five vaccines currently authorized
health canada and the public health
agency of canada are continuing to
actively monitor their safety in the
real world
and we monitor for any adverse events or
side effects in collaboration with the
provinces and territories international
partners and the manufacturers
as with all vaccines we will take action
if any safety issues are identified and
ongoing reporting of any potential side
effects is critical to supporting this
monitoring canadians can report any
possible side effects to their health
care professionals
now that another vaccine is authorized
for use in canada i know people will
want to know who will receive them and
when they will be available my
colleagues dr tam and dr new will speak
to this in a few moments after comments
from dr bertiel thank you merci
bonjour mercedes
hello
canada
yes
is
objectives
manufacturing instructions for ourselves
people who are vaccinated
is
is
and the terms
reactions
okay
is
foreign
as dr sharma and doctor
just announced today
as to health canada authorized novavac's
new vaccine cover 19 vaccine for use as
a primary series in adults 18 years of
age and over making it the first
protein-based covert-19 vaccine
authorized for use in canada
the public health agency of canada has
also released recommendations from the
national advisory committee on
immunization on nasi on the use of
novavax vaccine based on current
scientific evidence and nasty's expert
opinion
the clinical trial data available to
date show that novovax vaccine is
effective in preventing confirmed
symptomatic coveting disease in the
short term
through ongoing monitoring both the
public health agency of canada and
health canada will continue to gather
real-world data on the safety of the
vaccine including myocarditis and
pericarditis the duration of protection
and the vaccine's effectiveness against
the delta and omicron variants
a primary series of the novavax vaccine
is currently considered to be two doses
as with other covert 19 vaccines
people may receive two doses of novavax
or a mixed series
meaning one dose of the novovax vaccine
and one dose of another covert 19
vaccine
nasi continues to recommend mrna
vaccines for most people
due to their excellent protection and
well-established safety profiles which
are based on the large body of evidence
accumulated from hundreds of millions of
vaccines administered around the world
nasi recommends that the novovax vaccine
may be offered to individuals who are
unable or unwilling to receive an mrna
covered 19 vaccine
it is not currently authorized for use
as a booster dose but it may be offered
as a booster to individuals who are
unable or unwilling to receive an mrna
vaccine
regardless of which covid19 vaccine they
received for their primary series
it is anticipated that doses will begin
arriving in canada in march
once here provincial and territorial
governments will manage vaccine
administration
having more authorized covert 19
vaccines provides provinces and
territories with an additional option to
consider in their vaccination programs
as well it can help remove barriers to
vaccination by providing an additional
option to adults who have not yet
received a covenanting vaccine
at this time it is particularly
important that we continue doing what we
can to relieve the pressure on our
hospitals by closing vaccine coverage
gaps and layering on core personal
protective practices
vaccination is one of the strongest most
important layers of protection as being
up to date with your covert 19 vaccine
substantially lowers the risk of severe
illness
novavax's new vaccine covert 19 vaccine
offers a new option for protection for
people who have not yet been vaccinated
it is not too late to get your first
second or boosted dose of the cover 19
vaccines that are available to you
no vaccine is 100 effective so keep
layering up by wearing a high quality
well fitting mask or respirator avoiding
crowds and improving indoor ventilation
to
reduce your risk of covid19 thank you
merci
foreign
is
is
um
so
we have not yet received
is
um
for the timing there at the start uh
we're going to take questions uh we've
got two lined up on the call so far so i
will start with uh jacques gallon from
the toronto star
hi good afternoon uh my first question
is for dr sharma in terms of
the effectiveness against omicron so if
i understand correctly uh health canada
is still waiting on confirmatory data
about the effectiveness against omicron
so i'm wondering if you could explain
why not wait until you get that data
before authorizing the use of the
vaccine
sure so thank you you're right so the
major what we call pivotal trials were
done at a time where the alpha beta and
the gamma strains were the predominant
ones we did go to all of the vaccine
manufacturers as well as all of the
manufacturers for treatments against
covid19 and asked them to submit
information
about the potential effectiveness
against the omicron variant novavax did
provide some information that's
lab-based so in those lab-based studies
they did test their vaccine against the
omicron variant and what it showed was
that there were antibodies that were
formed
that doesn't give you a complete picture
but we know that the formation of those
neutralizing antibodies gives us a good
indication that there would be activity
against the omicron variant
in addition to that they do have ongoing
studies in adolescence and they released
some information from those last week
those were conducted in delta and delta
times where the delta wave was
predominant and there's likely some
omicron cases in there as well and so
far that data has shown that it would
likely be uh have some effectiveness
against that so when we look at that in
the context of all the information that
we have and what we know about the other
vaccines and how they work it does look
like there would be significant activity
against omicron so rather than wait to
authorize until we get all of that data
which might take some time
we know that there is a good a good
amount of supportive data to show that
there would probably be some some good
activity against omicron and as i
mentioned earlier there would be
requirements for them to continue to
provide data as it became available
great thanks a lot and my second
question i think it might be for dr tam
because it has to do with boosters and i
heard what you said about novovax and
boosters and i just wanted to make sure
i understood clearly that if an
individual were to get two doses of the
novovax vaccine would they be required
to get a booster dose and could that
booster dose be novavax
there's um currently
uh no available data um
well it's not authorized by health
canada the novo vac vaccine for as a
booster however
the national advisory committee on
immunization
uh has said that the the vaccine may be
offered as a boost the dose
um to individuals who are unable when
unwilling to get the mrna vaccine
but that is a
off-label use and that informed consent
would be
needed of course to discuss the benefits
of risk with the individuals
who are getting that booster
and that's very different from
what you've asked i believe in your
question about requirements and so
that's an entirely separate
uh discussion right now
there's no jurisdictions across canada
that i know of who is
adding that booster requirement
in their vaccine proves or
mandates but this is an area of ongoing
discussion
within the public health
domain
in the at the different levels of
government
perhaps to add to that i mean in terms
of how many doses are required it really
is depending on a couple of things one
is you know following people that have
had two doses to see what happens to
their immunity so when we talked about
third doses or booster doses for the
other vaccine is because we started
seeing some of that immunity wane or
decrease that's a monitoring that will
have to happen with the novavax vaccine
as well to see how long that protection
lasts
and then we would need studies to show
that
when you get a booster then it does
actually do something that it provides
that immune boost and we know that
novovax has already started to conduct
those studies for boosters so that's why
at this point in time we've authorized
the two doses and then based on those
ongoing studies when we get more
information that will be able to
indicate whether or not at their dose
would be needed and how long after the
second dose would be the best time to
get it
thank you our next question is from
kelly geraldine malone with the canadian
press i'm not sure who's best to answer
this but will the rollout in march be
vaccines that are manufactured in canada
um at that montreal facility
um i can answer that question no it
would not um it it is uh the top the
vaccine that we will be receiving
um in march will come from india from
the serum institute
in a follow-up to that um when is that
manufacturing facility for canada to
create its own vaccine supply expected
to be running now that this is approved
and
when
how much is expected to be kind of
brought into canada in those first
rounds of doses coming
so um i am going to have to
refer you to other departments on the
domestic site
timelines but
i will say that of course canada has
contracted for a significant supply of
novovax vaccine
and
we're currently working with the
province and territories to determine
the requirements uh given that the
majority of canadians have rolled up
their sleeves and got vaccines so that
is an ongoing work we do expect a supply
to come into march
that will be informed
also by the provincial territorial
requirements
but just stay tuned because there'll be
further
information provided
as we know more
and perhaps to add to that as well when
the vaccine is authorized we also
authorize different sites so those sites
have to meet what we call good
manufacturing practice standards they
have to be inspected to be able to
reliably manufacture vaccines so that
the first vaccine that comes off that
line is exactly the same as the
millionth dose that comes off that line
so for this authorization
as dr tan has said the syrian institute
of india facility has been authorized as
part of that as well as sites in the
united states in order for the canadian
site to be included in that
authorization it would have to
demonstrate that they can reliably
produce that vaccine
and before that happens um once they're
in production then health canada would
go in and inspect that site so the
reason we don't have a timeline yet for
it is because they haven't indicated to
us that they're ready to have that
inspection
but as soon as they're ready we have
inspectors on standby to go into the
facility to assure that it meets the
meets the standards but as we said the
first supply for novavax would be coming
in from the crm institute of india
thank you uh i have a question myself
and then we'll go back to the ones in
the queue it's dylan robertson with
winnipeg free press a question for dr
tan i wanted to know about public trust
and reporting of errors in vaccination
rollouts the manitoba government
mislabeled a box of pfizer doses and so
nurses at a first nation froze them for
too long and then administered shots
that were likely not effective
they're now working to rectify that
issue and give updated shots but the
manitoba government won't see whether it
mislabeled just one box or multiple
boxes
i know you don't run isk or provincial
systems but i'm wondering what amount of
disclosure these bodies owe to the
public about mistakes in order to shore
up vaccine confidence
i think that in the rollout of the
biggest vaccination campaign in the
history of canada there's always going
to be some bumps in the road
and um so so in such huge operational
um context
there will be some um
you know some mistakes that may have
been made or errors that needs to be
corrected i think the most important
thing is to of course learn from those
and rectify any specific
gaps in terms of lessons learned so i as
you say you know i actually don't know
any of the details
what i do know is that
different
people involved are trying to
gather the data and looking at
what happened and also i think health
canada also contributed in terms of
stability or other data related to
vaccines under certain conditions
so i think it is important for
um you know a clear communication
of what's uh went on um but i i can't
speak to any of the details
for sure thank you dr tan and just as a
follow-up
i don't know how you'd quantify this but
do you know how often this has happened
like is this the first time you've heard
in canada of like a mislabeled box or
you know doses that had expired getting
administered
i don't have that statistics
unfortunately but it i haven't heard of
any significant numbers that's that's
all i can say but i know that on the
operational level uh these events
can certainly occur but it would be rare
and if
we you know i certainly haven't heard of
that many uh instances
thank you very much uh we're going to go
back to the two participants on the call
unless anyone else shows up in the queue
here so uh first up is jacqueline with
the toronto star
hi at first i just wanted to ask a quick
clarification question about the doses
arriving in march i'm wondering can you
confirm how many doses are expected to
arrive in march
um i can't confirm that i think
there will be further updates uh for
example from public service and
procurement canada um which is
part of their responsibilities but on
our end we are consulting with the
province territories in terms of their
needs
thanks and then the question i did want
to ask is for you dr tam and it's on
testing the pre-departure testing
measures we heard announced this week
i've heard from members of the public
who are wondering
for and crossing the u.s for crossing
the land border into the u.s the u.s
does not require a pre-departure test
but a pre-departure test is required by
canada to cross the land border from the
u.s into canada so i'm wondering why
maintain that requirement
in
light of the fact that the u.s does not
have that requirement
yes so i think ministers had announced
the changes in border measures earlier
this week
and i'm sure all of those policies will
be reviewed on an ongoing basis
right now what we do know is that
there's quite a high positivity rate of
individuals who are tested as they
arrive in canada including those from
the united states
um so i think i do think that as the
omicron wave uh descends in canada
um the us is also observing a um
gradual um deceleration of their uh
omicron wave as well but right now there
is actually quite a high um
high level of viral
activity
and uh so we'll i think that those data
will be
re-evaluated on an ongoing basis
thank you our next question is kelly
geraldine malone from the canadian press
so considering um the recent data from
novovax in regards to the efficacy of
the vaccine in children how far is
health canada away from having this
approved for use in children here
especially considering lots of parents
have shown hesitancy around mrna
vaccines for their kids
right so a week ago a week ago today
novobax released some interim uh
preliminary results from their
pediatrics trial for in adolescence and
that was in ages uh 12 to 17 and it did
show good response immune response in
that age group so uh novax is going
through that data it's assembling it and
assessing it and they're expected to
provide uh health canada with a
submission in the coming weeks but we
haven't received that yet as soon as we
get it we would we would review it on a
priority basis as we do with all the
covid19 vaccines
and if it meets the standards we would
authorize it but we still haven't
received it yet
uh i i don't know if uh you had a
follow-up kelly
uh no go ahead
okay i i think that ends our press
conference then uh i i want to thank
everyone for uh for sharing these
answers today and this information and
stay safe out there
you too thank you